la colombie britannique a connu la pire
saison de feu de forêt de son histoire 6
ans incendie de plus que l'année
précédente
65000 personnes évacuées 300 structures
détruites des flamands qui prennent
beaucoup de temps à se mettre en place
comme des fous de foire et donc ça prend
des sécheresses seulement un manque de
pluie beaucoup de soleil de chaleur
ainsi donc ça va aider à partir des feux
de forêt ont des changements climatiques
ne cause pas le phénomène ne vont
vraiment l'ampli les vagues de chaleur
estivales ont fait au moins 90 victimes
au pays
le temps chaud et sec suivies de chutes
de neige a ruiné des récoltes dans les
prairies dans l'est début mai une grosse
tempête qui commence en ontario pour se
diriger jusqu'à montréal québec cause
pour un milliard de dollars de dommages
la plus destructrice des cinq dernières
années
quand on vit présentement c'est vraiment
un événement qui était beaucoup plus
rare de l'époque de nos grands parents
dans quelque chose qui était
exceptionnel et maintenant que l'année
prochaine décennie ou sûrement faire
donner beaucoup plus commun par la
population de l'outaouais de l'est de
l'ontario n'oubliera pas les tornades du
dernier jour de l'été avec ses vents qui
ont atteint 265 kilomètres à l'heure
mais on détruit toits arrachés des
dizaines de personnes hospitalisées
tout pays a été prouvé de la crue éclair
de la rivière saint-jean au
nouveau-brunswick jusqu'au début du mois
de dhou à toronto
les environnementalistes y voit des
signes clairs qu'il faut intensifier nos
efforts pour réduire nos gaz à effet de
serre
la première priorité c'est de protéger
l'intégrité des des humains dans la
sécurité la santé parce que si on
continue à augmenter nos gaz à effet de
serre ces événements là vont s'amplifier
vont devenir de plus en plus intense de
plus en plus fréquents l'an dernier nous
avons eu des froids record annonciateur
de l'ong hiver qui sait ce que 2019 nous
apportera ici se lever et miley radio
canada montréal